one week after Hurricane Maria
devastated Puerto Rico the federal
government says more supplies and work
crews are on the way food water and fuel
are still hard to find power outages
make it difficult to contact those in
need at least 16 people have died there
and that number could rise Porto Rico's
governor spoke with President Trump by
video about the situation yesterday
we're going to hear from the governor in
just a moment the president plans to
visit Puerto Rico next week on Tuesday
he says he has defended his actions
after facing criticism by some lawmakers
for a slow response David Berg know is
in San Juan with the effort to give
survivors exactly what they need David
good morning good morning we just got
some information that's starting to
clear up some of the confusion about why
it may be taking so long to get food and
water to people on this island who
haven't had it for four or five days the
governor just told us they're desperate
for drivers he said look I've got food
and water sitting at the port it's ready
to go but I don't have the people to
drive it to the stores so I said to the
governor okay so what are you doing and
he said we're literally asking anyone
bus drivers commercial truck drivers
anyone who can drive a truck legally who
can help us please come
you would drive food water to parts of
the island that are so desperate now you
can't get to all parts of the island the
governor told us yesterday he flew over
an area where people still had signs on
their roof on what was left of their
home begging for help
so rescues continues seven days after
Hurricane Maria made land
fimA the man who's running the operation
here told us they have ten thousand
personnel and they've delivered aid
almost every part of the island but
people have come to us people in the
u.s. have come to us and said I want
proof show me it's being done so we've
asked FEMA take us will you take us
there and let us get video they said yes
they promised us a trip today
but we just got a note that it's not
going to happen today it'll be tomorrow
now about the hospital's only 30 percent
of the hospitals on the island are
functioning take for example the one
here in San Juan de the maestro okay
here's what's happening at that hospital
you've got only one floor the ICU that
has air conditioning only two other
floors have lights and adults and
children have been grouped together if
you need a surgery there people are
being prioritized by who is critically
ill who sort of tops that this the mayor
of San Juan says hospitals at least here
in this area are being run by generative
power and according to the mayor if they
run out of power and look diesel is
there's a shortage of eëtion that the
mayor said if they run out of power nor
they're going to run out of light
David beg no in San Juan thank you